- [Narrator] This
program is a presentation
of UCTV for educational and
non-commercial use only.
(soft instrumental music)
- Good afternoon, I'm Andrew Serry,
Dean of the Graduate Division.
We're pleased along with
the graduate council
to present Robert Reich,
this year's speaker
in the Barbara Weinstock
Memorial Lecture Series.
In 1902, Harris Weinstock,
a well-known businessman
of Sacramento presented the
University of California
with a fund to support
an annual public lecture
on the morals of trade on
behalf of his wife, Barbara.
Weinstock was fundamentally committed
to the economic and moral
progress of humankind.
He wrote many newspaper columns
and gave numerous lectures on topics
ranging from Napoleon to socialism.
Inspired by Spencer and Newton's essays
on the morals of trade
which lamented the state of morals
in the mid 19th century business world
he argued that a man does not profit
if he gains the whole world
and loses his soul.
Harris Weinstock hoped
that this lectureship
would lead to a better life for those
who spent their lives
in commercial pursuits.
He said, and I quote,
"Let men and women the world over
"worship character rather than wealth.
"Let them do homage to the high-minded
"and pure-minded rather than
the merely rich and powerful.
"And the ideal age will be at hand
"when trade will carry
with it the badge of honor
"and the successful man of business
"will take the high
place hitherto confined
"to the patriot and faithful
servant of mankind."
End quote.
Past lecturers who have delivered
the Barbara Weinstock Memorial Lectures
on the Morals of Trade include;
Ralph Nader,
member of Parliament, Neil Kinnock
and Nobel Laureate Amartya Sen.
And now I'd like to welcome
Professor Karlene Roberts,
the Chair of the Weinstock
Lectureship Committee
to the podium to
introduce Professor Reich.
- Before I introduce
Professor Reich to you,
all of you I'm sure know
a great deal about him
or you wouldn't be here.
But before I do that I'd like to explain
why if you look on the
back of your program
you'll find that there has never been
a Weinstock lecturer who was
on the faculty at Berkeley
at the time he was asked to
be the Weinstock lecturer.
And the reason is pretty simple,
we forgot.
So at our meeting to select this lecturer
as Chair of the Weinstock Committee
I said, "Look guys"
by the way it is guys except for Ellen,
"we have never had a professor
who's on this faculty
"and look at all the
sterling professors we have
"beginning with Robert Reich."
And that was the end of that conversation.
So I want to welcome you all
and Professor Reich today
and I'm not gonna say too much about him
because you have a little blurb about him
and most of you know about him
and I've seen his books flying
around here pretty well.
He is the Chancellor's
Professor of Public Policy
at the Goldman School
here at Berkeley, ra!
And he was as you probably know
the 22nd Secretary of Labor.
He was voted by Time Magazine as being
one of the most outstanding
secretaries of labor.
He's written quite a bit.
I hear him on the radio quite a bit.
And so I think we're all
anxious to get on with it
and listen to Professor Reich.
I just wanted to tell you
something I didn't know,
he graduated from Dartmouth
and then he went on to be
Rhode's Scholar at Oxford
and then he got a law degree from Yale.
And he has talked to the Supreme Court
on the part of the U.S. government.
May I welcome, Robert Reich.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, Professor Roberts.
And thank you all for coming today.
A couple of other points need to be said,
about Harris Weinstock and this lecture,
The Morals of Trade,
many of you in this audience know
that about 12 years
before Harris Weinstock
endowed this lecture
and conceived of this lecture
in 1890, the great
economist Alfred Marshall
wrote his Principles of Economics.
Before that time economics
was not really thought of
as a separate discipline.
In most of the 19th century
it was all called moral,
political economy.
And before that in the 18th century
it was all called moral philosophy.
Adam Smith did not consider
himself an economist,
obviously, did not even
really consider himself
a political economist.
He thought of himself
as a moral philosopher.
And so even though I'm going to be talking
to you a lot about economics and politics
really underlying what I am saying
are questions and ethics,
questions as how we live together
as members of the same society
and members of really the same
human species on the globe.
We're all reminded of that notion
that we're all together as
members of the same human species
on the globe
and what we do is inevitably
going to affect what others do,
directly or indirectly,
by the terrible tragedy
now unfolding in Japan.
It is first and foremost a human tragedy
and also an environmental tragedy.
We don't know the dimensions yet
and probably like you I have been getting
every piece of information I possibly can.
But it is also way down the list
an economic tragedy.
Japan is the third largest
economy in the world,
in fact of developed economies,
so called advanced economies,
Japan is second only to us.
Which means that we
have an enormous amount
of trade with Japan.
Japan owns a lot of our debt,
a lot of treasury bills.
What happens in Japans inevitably,
quite apart from the human suffering,
quite apart from the
environmental degradation,
quite apart from these
very, very important
primary issues,
there is also the economic interdependence
and the economic consequences
which I'll get to in a moment.
A question I want to
address with you today
is what is going to happen
over the next few years?
In an economy, that is
the United States economy,
that is having a painfully difficult time
getting out of the gravitational pull
of The Great Recession.
Now if you listen
to people on Wall Street,
if you appear as I do on CNBC
or listen to, I don't know
how many of you actually watch CNBC?
Don't be embarrassed.
That's about what I expected.
(audience laughing)
I debate people on CNBC
and on MSNBC and
occasionally on the networks
and what passes for
economic discussion on CNBC
is very much Wall Street's point of view.
That is the issue is
what's going to happen
to stocks and bonds,
it's not really the economy or at least,
perhaps I should say it this way.
The economy is defined as Wall Street,
as stocks and bonds.
And that is not to criticize
CNBC or anybody else,
that's what the business
pages of the newspapers
tell us that's what many experts focus on
because so many people are dependent
on what happens on Wall Street,
they want to know, their
retirement income depends on it.
Their future security depends on it,
they like to know where
Wall Street is heading.
And I will tell you,
before the end of our 45 minutes
I'll tell you exactly
where Wall Street is going.
(audience laughing)
I'll do it very rapidly,
so listen carefully.
You may miss it because it's so,
it will occur so rapidly.
But that's not the economy,
the real American economy is
different from Wall Street.
If you listen only to the
cheerleaders on Wall Street
you see, we've had a huge bull market,
things are almost back to
where they were before.
The Dow Jones Industrial Average
is over 12,000.
Well that's not quite
where it was in 2007,
but it's still getting way up there.
And on top of that corporate
executives salaries
and bonuses on Wall Street
are just about back to where they were.
And things are looking very good.
Yes, there is some concern
about the consequences of
the United States economy
of what's happened in Japan
and there is some worry about oil prices
given what's happening in the Middle East.
But generally speaking
there's an enormous,
almost buoyant confidence
that comes out of Wall Street
and out of corporate America.
Corporate profits by the way
are soaring.
They really have in my experience
never been if you look at the major,
large American corporations
almost never this high.
Big companies in the United States
are sitting on 1.8
trillion dollars of cash.
Now those estimates vary
between 1.4 trillion
and 1.9 trillion.
I saw yesterday at the end
of 2010 it was 1.9 trillion,
it's very difficult to estimate.
It's hard to get, but we
know it's a very big number.
There's a lot of money and
they are sitting on it,
it's in the form of cash.
Which means that big
companies don't even know
really what to do with it.
Normally, normally after a recession
when large companies begin showing profits
they take those profits
and they invest them
in additional capacity.
Which means more jobs,
not immediately.
There is typically a jobless recovery,
at least until businesses
start feeling confident
that consumers out there will buy
and are capable of buying
all of the goods and services
that those companies
are capable of producing
at full employment.
But then employment cranks up
and you get a virtuous cycle
because as employment goes up
and people get more wages
and they feel more confident
and they feel more secure they buy more
and as they buy more the
economy naturally rises.
Most of the business
cycle in this country,
at least most of our recent experiences
with the business cycle,
by the cycle I'm talking about the cycle
of exuberance and expansion
and then overshooting
which leads to a kind
of downward momentum,
often recession is the ending point.
Most of those cycles,
those business cycles,
are really brought about by
the Federal Reserve Board.
And the Federal Reserve
Board either overshoots
or undershoots.
The Fed either raises
interest rates too high,
trying to ward off inflation
or it keeps interest rates too low
and generates just too
much economic activity
given the capacity of the
country to avoid inflation.
And that's what it is usually,
but something is different this time.
Something is different this time,
profoundly different.
There is a decoupling
between the profits that the
big companies are showing
and the extraordinary gains
on Wall Street on the one hand
and job growth on the other.
There's a decoupling between how people
at the top are doing
and they are doing extraordinarily well.
I'm talking about the top
1% on the income scale
or the top 1% on the wealth scale
or even the top 1/10th of 1%
to make a point even more dramatically,
they've never done as well.
There's a dramatic gap
between how they are doing
and how everyone else is
doing in this recovery.
And going back to Harris
Weinstock's concern
about the morality of trade
or the morality of our commercial system
something seems out of whack.
And many people are asking themselves
what's going on?
Now again if you think of this
as just the normal business cycle
you would expect that when
the Federal Reserve Board
kept interest rates near zero or at zero
for as long as it has
we would see a lot of borrowing going on
and that borrowing would
generate more economic activity.
You would think when we
had as much spending,
at least until recently,
as we had at the Federal government level
that that would have generated enough
of a so-called multiplier effect.
That is every one who benefited
directly by the spending
would have more money in their pockets,
they would turn around and buy more
and so on that that would
also have contributed
to a vigorous recovery.
You would expect that fiscal
and monetary policies,
as those are called,
would by now have kicked in.
And given how deep a hole
we have found ourselves in
in this Great Recession
you would think that by now
not only would unemployment
start really dropping
but also the economy would start growing.
I mean if you're in a hole
to get back to the surface,
back to where you were before,
you do need more than normal growth.
I mean think of the economy
of sort of,
almost a climb, a kind
of you're moving uphill.
The economy is growing,
but when you fall into
a hole on that climb
then you need to have faster growth
in order to just get back to the surface
where you can then resume
the growth you had before.
So what we would normally assume would be,
instead of 2.5 and or 3% growth now,
we would assume four, or
five, or 6% or 7% growth.
It's not happening.
Mystery upon mystery.
Something is different.
Well I wanna talk about that
because it seems to me
that what really is happening
has a lot to do with
long-term structural changes
in the economy,
changes that have a lot in
turn to do with inequality,
of income and wealth
and opportunity
and political power.
No one likes to talk
about political power,
I will.
And less and less to do
with the business cycle
and this is why it seems to me
that people are looking in
the wrong place for answers.
Don't get me wrong,
I do think the Fed needs
to keep interest rates
as low as possible.
I do think
and wish Washington were prepared
to expand fiscal policy.
I think it's the height of folly
for congress and for
the president right now,
right now to be concerned
about budget deficits.
Yes, be concerned about it three or four
or five years from now
when we are out of the gravitational pull
of The Great Recession.
But right now when we need
as much aggregate demand as possible,
when consumers are still scared,
when businesses are still
sitting on so much money
because they don't think
that there are customers
out there for their goods and services.
When we have unemployment
as high as we do,
nationally, 8.9%, 8.8%,
but also almost 14 million
Americans unemployed,
half of them unemployed for
a very long period of time.
This is no time to pull in your horns
and start cutting and
whacking budget deficits.
And oil prices are going up
and at the same time state
governments are pulling in
and cutting their budgets.
And many of the things that are being cut
are desperately important
to the working class and the middle class
and the poor who are
suffering enormously in this.
Don't do it, not now.
But having made that
point I want to go beyond
and talk about inequality.
Here it seems to me
is the terrain that we
really need to traverse
in terms of understanding
what's happening.
The typical 30-year-old man,
and I'll explain to you in a moment
why I'm talking about the 30-year-old man,
the typical 30-year-old man today,
if he has a job
is earning, adjusted for inflation,
no more than the typical
30-year-old man earned
three decades ago.
Adjusted for inflation.
Or to put it a different way
if you look at the bottom 90% of Americans
and looked at their average wage,
adjusted for inflation,
each worker would be
doing a little bit better,
that is would earn this year about $280
more than he or she
earned three decades ago.
That's not much to show
over three decades.
The American economy is much larger,
it's twice as large as it was
three decades ago.
And yet the median wage for
those lucky enough to have jobs
has gone nowhere and if
anything it's gone down.
Why?
What's going on and how does this relate
to The Great Recession
and the difficulty
we're having getting out
of The Great Recession.
How does this relate
to questions of ethics
and morality?
And also where did all the money go?
I mean if the American
economy is twice as large
as it was 30 years ago
and if the median wage is
pretty much stuck in neutral
then you've got to have some idea
of where all the gains went.
If you're in the top 1%
you are not stuck in neutral,
your share of total income doubled
over the last 30 years.
If they're in the top 1/10th of 1%,
your share of the national income tripled
over the last 30 years.
We haven't seen this degree
on concentration of income
and wealth is even more concentrated,
since the 1920s.
More about that in a moment.
How have working families
over the last 30 years
managed to maintain
their standard of living?
How have they managed
to continue to spend?
Well, one of three ways.
The first way was women
going into paid work.
In great numbers, starting
in the late 1970s,
increasing in the 1980s,
increasing again in the 1990s.
A huge number of women
in the United States
went into paid work.
I wish I could tell you it was all because
of the wonderful,
professional opportunities
open to professional women
beginning in the late 70s
and starting in the 80s.
No, that was not the primary reason.
The primary reason that
women went into paid work
in great numbers, even
those with young children,
was because they needed
to in order to prop up
family incomes where male wage earners
were actually showing declines in wages.
That's the only way
they could keep up their living standards.
But you know we come to an
end of that coping mechanism.
In the 1960s, to give an example,
only about 20% of women
with young children
were in the paid workforce.
I say paid, because women
always were working.
The question is whether
they were getting paid for their work.
And 20% of American women in the 1960s
with young children were
in the paid workforce.
By the 1980s and 1990s
we were up to 50 and 60%,
in fact by the 1990s it
was up to 60% of women
with young children were
in the paid workforce.
Well you can't go much beyond that.
American families had to search
for a second coping mechanism,
a way of keeping going.
And the second coping mechanism
was for everybody to work longer hours.
When I was secretary of labor
I remember looking over the data
on the number of hours
Americans were working
and I couldn't believe it.
In terms of overtime, in
terms of billable hours,
in terms of second jobs,
in terms of third jobs.
Americans had never worked
that long, that hard,
350 hours a year longer
than the typical European.
Longer even than they
typical worker in Japan.
Two incomes, everybody working longer,
I used to have a demographic term I used,
DINS, D-I-N-S.
Double income, no sex.
(audience laughing)
I don't know how we
reproduced in those years.
And then that obviously was exhausted,
that second coping mechanism
because there are only a
certain number of hours
people can work.
And right about then, late 1990s,
a third coping mechanism came along.
It was almost as if there were trapezes
and you moved from one to the other.
There is just a trapeze just in time
to save us, to enable us
to keep on maintaining
our standard of living
and that third coping mechanism,
that third trapeze was
rising housing values
that enabled the working-middle-class
to refinance their homes
or to take out home equity loans
all of which enabled people to live
better than they otherwise could live,
going deeper and deeper into debt.
But the rising home values seemed
an easy means of maintaining that debt.
Well, that proved elusory.
When I came to Berkeley in 2006
I had an opportunity,
I was very, very fortunate to get an offer
from the University of
California, Berkeley
to come and teach here
leaving the East Coast,
leaving the weather on the East Coast,
leaving snow and sleet
and horrid summers
and everything that you
don't even know about
that occurs.
But I bought a house,
I bought a house here in Berkeley.
I think it was April, I
think it was the first week
of April of 2006.
Which is important for you to know
because that was when the housing market
reached its zenith.
(audience laughing)
You see my investment
strategy has always been,
buy high, sell low.
(audience laughing)
Those extraordinary houses
values couldn't keep up.
The debt load couldn't be maintained.
There was no way that,
that's what turned out to
be a speculative bubble,
could continue.
And obviously it didn't.
That debt bubble burst
and when it burst the final
coping mechanism also burst.
There was no way that the typical American
could continue to maintain
the same living standard
and continue to be a customer,
continue to consume
in ways that Americans had
for three decades before.
And without customers,
without as many customers,
without people being as willing to buy
the economy is not going
to hire that many people.
Companies are not going to hire,
the entire wheels of commerce begin
grinding to a halt.
Now I know that the version of events
that you have in your head
about why The Great Recession occurred
has much more to do with
Wall Street's excesses
than anything I've said to you so far.
And I don't want to let
Wall Street off the hook.
Wall Street did over reach.
And regulators who were
supposed to look at Wall Street
did look the other way.
I'm just saying that
behind all of this lies
a deeper, structural story.
That has more to do with the plights
of the working and
middle classes of America
and stagnate incomes.
And the final failure of
the third coping mechanism
which was debt to enable
people to continue
to buy as before.
Right after President Obama was elected
he had a meeting
of several of his economic
advisors in Chicago
and I attended the meeting.
And I remember Paul Volcker was there
along with my colleague at Berkeley,
Laura Tyson and several others.
Paul Volcker, as you may know,
was the former head of
the Federal Reserve Board.
He's very, very tall,
he's remarkably tall,
he's irresponsibly tall.
(audience laughing)
I mean in environmental terms,
he uses up more energy
and exudes more carbon
than anybody I know.
But in any event we were talking about
The Great Recession
and of course this is
a very important time.
The new president has just been elected.
Things look like they're collapsing
and they were collapsing
and the new president wants to know why,
what's going on.
And Paul Volcker I remember said,
"Mr. President, yes Wall
Street has gone berserk
"and exceeded the boundaries
that we expect of Wall Street
"and there wasn't adequate regulation
"but underlying all of
this, Mr. President,
"underlying all of this
"is the simple fact that Americans
"spent more than they earned.
"They lived beyond their
means for too long."
Lived beyond our means,
we have lived beyond our means.
That's what Paul Volcker's view was
and that view you can still see around.
It is a rather moralistic view
to go back to Harris Weinstock.
But then Laura Tyson, my colleague here,
piped up and she said,
"No, Paul, I think you're wrong.
"I don't think the underlying problem
"is Americans spent beyond their means,
"or lived beyond their means,
"I think the problem is their means
"did not keep up."
and of course Laura was absolutely right.
Their means did not keep up
with what we would expect
an expanding economy, a
growing economy, to permit.
Now this being Berkeley
many of you in this room, obviously,
and I don't mean to
sound in any way snarky
about the comment I'm about to make.
But this being Berkeley,
may of you in this room
think about consumption
in a way that many people in
the rest of this country don't
think about it.
That is to you, consumption
is just the acquisition
of a lot of material goods,
just filling up houses with stuff.
And maybe, although I don't
really want to presume
to read your heads,
maybe you may be saying to yourself,
"Look, what's wrong with
us not consuming as much?"
In fact we are consuming too much.
We are consuming about a quarter
of the world's energy resources.
Maybe it's a good thing that
we're not consuming as much?
I want to draw a distinction,
just for you in this room
and for anybody who's
watching on streaming video,
(audience laughing)
between consumption and consumerism.
What you may be worried about
and I worry about it too
is just a mentality of consuming
more and more and more.
No, I'm talking about
consumption in broader terms,
it's not just individuals or families
buying and consuming
it's also public goods.
It's what we as a people,
as a nation are able to afford to do.
It's better education and more education.
It's more healthcare
and better healthcare.
It's public transportation,
it's all sorts of things
that also could if we did more of it
utilize our productive
capacity as a nation.
Some of that will actually
be on a better environment,
we can if we spend more
and this sounds ironic and paradoxical,
but if we spend more we
might actually be able
to move away from carbon fuels.
It means some investments
in basic research
in non-carbon-based fuels,
you get my drift.
I just want you to, in your heads,
I want to cut off what I
expect some questions might be,
isn't it good that we are
not consuming as much?
Again, consumerism, this is not
an argument for consumerism,
this is an argument for
having enough aggregate demand
in the system to keep the system going.
And that aggregate demand could come
from a variety of
sources including sources
that are public goods that
everybody in this room
or most of you might approve of.
Now,
I want to go back because
some of you may having heard this story
want to understand,
because obviously what I'm doing now
is trying to explain why we are
in the predicament we're in,
why it's so hard to get out
of the gravitational pull
of The Great Recession.
What we need to do next,
what we need to do next.
What I'm trying to lay the foundation for
is that kind of next move,
how do we get out of the
predicament that we're in.
Some of you may be asking
yourselves right now,
what do we know
about why beginning three decades ago?
So much of the nations income and wealth
started going to the top.
I mean there must be some
reason for all of this
and did it ever happen before?
The answer is yes and yes,
there is a reason and
it did happen before.
And by looking at when it happened before
we can get a glimpse at or a clue
as to why it began happening again
beginning in the late 70s
and beginning in the 1980s
and maybe that will give us some notion
of what to do next.
Of what we need to do next.
In 2007
the top 1% by income in the United States
got 23.5% of total national income.
Now as I said to your before
that was more than double
what they had 30 years before.
30 years before they
were getting about nine
or nine-and-a-half percent
of total national income.
Now go back in time in the United States
and ask yourself when
was it that the top 1%
had anything close to 23.5%
of total national income?
Was there another time?
And if you look at the data
what you see is that
there was another time,
in fact there was another year
that almost remarkably, exactly parallels
the peak year of 2007, in terms
of concentration of income.
And that other year is 1928.
(audience laughing)
And then came 1929,
now I'm not suggesting
that The Great Crash
and also the 2008 crash,
were necessarily only responsive
to these widening disparities
but there are very important parallels.
The head of the Federal Reserve Board
between 1934 and 1948,
was a man named Marriner Eccles.
How many of you have
heard of Marriner Eccles?
Put up your hand.
I'm surprised, 17 of you.
(audience laughing)
Marriner Eccles, in
researching my latest book
about all of this,
I came across Marriner Eccles work
on The Great Depression.
Marriner Eccles
came to the conclusion
that The Great Depression
was a function of widening inequality
because he said,
"So much income concentrated at the top
"that the only way the
vast majority of Americans
could keep spending and
maintain the economy
and the government could keep maintaining
to the extent that the government
was spending in those days
was
by means of going deeper
and deeper into debt.
And that debt bubble
could not be sustained.
It exploded.
And it exploded in 1929.
And so there is a very powerful parallel.
What did Franklin D. Roosevelt do?
He did two things.
Belatedly,
one of them he did very poorly.
One of them it turned out he did very well
but he didn't know he was doing it.
What did Barrack Obama do
after 2008?
Well he did one of the things
that Franklin D. Roosevelt did do,
but he did it much better
than Franklin D. Roosevelt did,
but he didn't do the other thing
that Franklin D. Roosevelt did.
Let me stop being so opaque.
(audience laughing)
Franklin D. Roosevelt, first of all,
there was a liquidity crisis,
a banking crisis.
What Franklin D. Roosevelt did
and he built upon Herbert Hoover,
he basically closed the banks,
he tried to provide some more liquidity.
He didn't know exactly what he was doing,
there were runs on banks.
You remember Jimmy Stewart,
It's a Wonderful Life.
You're money is in her property
and her money is in your property,
it didn't matter there
were still runs on banks.
But Franklin D. Roosevelt did try to stop
the runs on the banks
with pumping in more money,
not nearly enough.
The Obama Administration
learned from that.
Ben Bernanke was a student,
he'd written a lot about
The Great Depression
and others in the, both the
George W. Bush Administration,
but more importantly in
the Obama Administration
understand the important
of flooding the economy
with liquidity, of getting
confidence in the banks back,
even to the extent of giving
the banks, the major banks,
a taxpayer funded bailout.
Now it's easy to say in retrospect,
but even at the time I was advising
that the bailout of the banks be connected
to conditions put on the banks.
Conditions such as supporting legislation
that would allow homeowners
to declare bankruptcy
on their first homes and thereby give them
a little bit more leverage
in their negotiations
with lenders.
Putting caps on bonuses and so forth,
but none of this happened.
But nevertheless,
this was the lesson that came out
of The Great Depression,
what you do when you
have a banking crisis,
when you have a financial crisis.
And I think that really,
the Obama Administration
apart from not being
tough enough with banks
did that pretty well.
We avoided a meltdown.
Unfortunate choice of words right now.
But what the Obama
Administration did not do
that Franklin D. Roosevelt did do,
and herein lies the very important
lesson unlearned.
Franklin D. Roosevelt
took an economy in which the gap
between the very rich, the super rich
and everybody else was
growing immeasurably
and did several things that
actually changed the equation.
Number one, the Wagner Act,
the National Labor Relations Act in 1935
creating a right to collective bargaining.
Imposing on employers
the duty to bargain in
good faith with employees.
That it turned out had a huge effect,
by the 1950s when 35% of
Americans were in trade unions.
And those, I'm talking
about American workers,
and those were not in trade unions
benefited by the negotiations
that unions created with employers
because the prevailing wages
really were set even
in the non-union sector
by employers who feared
that if they did not mimic
what was in those labor agreements
they would be next to become unionized.
So it had an effect all over the economy.
Franklin D. Roosevelt also
created a minimum wage.
A 40-hour workweek with time-and-a-half
for overtime.
Social Security
including aid for families
with dependent children,
disability came later.
A long list of things that we
almost take for granted now.
Unemployment insurance, 1938.
All of the foundation
stones for a modern economy
based on the idea
that workers are also consumers.
And there's no way in which
an economy can function
unless that basic bargain linking workers
and their productivity to their pay
so that they can turn around and consume
would be maintained.
By the 1950s
not only did we have all of that
but we also had a GI Bill,
many Americans were attending college.
We had a huge investment in infrastructure
under Eisenhower,
the National Defense Highway Act
creating the entire
Interstate Highway System.
After Sputnik, investments
in the education
and training of a whole
generation of science
and mathematics teachers
and new investments in the classrooms
in terms of math and science teaching.
We rebuilt Europe in those years.
We rebuilt Japan.
How did we do that after
the Second World War?
Well in part because our economy
was growing very fast.
But I remember we also had a huge deficit.
In fact we came out of World War II
with a national debt that was
as a proportion of our
whole national product
over 100%.
The national debt was larger
than the yearly national
product of the United States
after World War II.
I remember in 1950, my father,
this was my first economics lesson,
my father saying to me,
"Bobby, you and your children
"and your children's children
"will be paying the national debt
"created by Franklin D. Roosevelt."
It scared the hell out of me.
(audience laughing)
I remember I couldn't sleep.
I didn't know what national debt was,
(audience laughing)
but I knew it would
haunt me and my children
and my children's children.
But my father, who was
right about most things,
was wrong.
How did we afford all of that?
Well we afforded it
because the economy grew
so buoyantly.
Because that pact between workers
and employers,
many of the investments
that had been made in education
and infrastructure began to pay off.
Also the marginal income tax,
on the highest earners,
was substantially higher.
Coming out of the Second World War
it was over 70%
and under Dwight D. Eisenhower,
who nobody to my mind has ever
accused of being a socialist,
Republican, former general,
Dwight D. Eisenhower,
the marginal income tax on the top earners
was 91%.
Now of the effective rate,
when you got rid of all the deductions
and the tax credits, was lower than that
but still much, much higher
than anybody is talking about today.
My point to you
is that the legacy of The New Deal
right through
Truman and Eisenhower,
right through John F. Kennedy and Johnson,
right through those years
those legacies of public investment
and shared prosperity
and shared sacrifice
and a deal, a basic bargain
between employers and employees
built a new American economy.
That grew faster than the
economy has ever grown since
in those 30 years after the
Second World War, we grew,
we grew.
Sometimes people ask me
when I talk about where we should go,
I talk about the principles
of shared prosperity
and shared sacrifice.
I talk about public
investment in education
and infrastructure,
basic research and development.
I talk about renewing the bargain
between employers and employees.
People say to me,
name a nation,
What are you talking
about the Netherlands,
the Netherlands or Sweden or Norway,
they're not like us.
Are you talking about Canada?
They're socialists up there.
People say to me
and I get on these talk shows
and people form the Cato Institute
and the Heritage Foundation,
they say, you're a socialist.
You're talking about Scandinavia.
And I say no, I'm talking
about the United States.
For the 30 years after
the Second World War
we did it here.
And if we did it in the 30 years after
the Second World War
there's no reason we can't do it again.
In terms of those principles,
we can't exactly replicate
precisely what we did then.
We've got to do something different
and we can talk about individual
specific public policies,
all I'm saying to you
is that those principles have
got to guide us once again.
And going back to Harris Weinstock
and his concern about morals and trade,
fundamentally, fundamentally
these principles are ethical principles
about how we live together.
It's just coincidental
that these principles
also support a vibrant
and buoyant economy.
In other words, if we
adhere to these principles
we all gain.
Even people at the top would do better
to have a smaller percentage
of a rapidly growing buoyant economy
than they would with a larger percentage
as they have now of an economy
that is anemic.
And prone more than ever
before to booms and busts.
One final point and then
I invite your questions.
There's a great deal of anger
in America if you haven't seen it
or experienced it already.
On one of these talk shows
that I alluded to before
on television, not long ago,
the producer during a station break
said to me in my ear piece,
"You need to be angrier."
(audience laughing)
And I said, "I'm sorry,
"I thought we were
having a very respectful,
"good discussion, I don't
want to be angrier."
And she said, "You have to be angrier."
And I said, "Why do I have to be angrier?"
And she said, "You have to be angrier
"because people are surfing
through the channels
"and they stop when people
are yelling at each other."
(audience laughing)
"Because it's like a gladiator contest,
"it's very exciting."
And I said, "I don't want to do that."
And she said, "You must."
And I'm afraid at that
point I lost my temper.
(audience laughing)
But I think the reason that people
when they are surfing through channels
want a gladiator contest
has something to do with
the degree of frustration,
anxiety and anger so many
people feel out there.
Who want to work,
who know that they've played by the rules,
who feel that somehow the
game is rigged against them.
A few days ago I got a
call from somebody who,
and I checked on this,
was an organizer of The Tea Party.
And I said, "It's very
interesting to talk to you
"because I know we don't see
eye-to-eye on many issues."
but it turned out after
about 45 minutes of talking
I discovered that there was
a great deal of overlap.
One of the most surprising
points of overlap
that I hadn't really thought through
but this person reminded me,
the Tea Party got it's start
in a kind of revulsion against
the bail out of Wall Street,
that's what started it.
And I asked,
"Well why are you so
much against government,
"why are you not against
Wall Street and big business?
"Why have you taken out your
ire against government?"
And the response I got back
was because we don't trust
that government is not
going to be in the pocket
of big business and Wall Street.
Well I can't say that I became
a Tea Partier at that moment,
(audience laughing)
but I at least understand
that there's a vast overlap
between progressives who are very upset
about the direction things are going
and Tea Partiers and
others who are very upset.
And I'm not talking about the fellow
who yells out the window,
"I'm mad as hell and I'm not
gonna stand for it anymore."
I'm talking about genuine, upset
that is based upon some sense
that the game is rigged
in favor of those with wealth and power.
So what we also need to do
in addition to adhering to
principles of shared prosperity
and shared sacrifice
a new contract between
labor and management
and also public investment.
What we also need to do
is dedicate ourselves
to freeing our democracy
from the scourge of big money.
The decision by the
Supreme Court last year
in Citizens United against the
Federal Election Commission
was one of the most grotesque decisions
ever enunciated by the
Supreme Court, in my view.
(audience applauding)
And I have no doubt
that with a few new
Supreme Court appointees,
hopefully from President Obama
or his successor who has the same values
that case will be reversed.
If not we are going to see
the game rigged more and more.
More big money from big corporations,
the attempt to reduce taxes on the rich,
the attempt to starve government
and make it impossible for people
to have the education
and the infrastructure
and the public investments
that they so desperately need.
While all the time
turning people in the middle
class and working class
against each other,
against public employees.
Against the poor, against immigrants,
against unions,
against China.
You see how many scapegoats there are?
We've got to get beyond scapegoating
and we've got to return
to original principles
that we learned 75 years ago.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
(soft instrumental music)